hi there today we're looking at meta
learning with implicit gradients by
Arwen rajeshwar on Chelsea Finn shank
Akkad and Sergey Lavine so this paper
deals with the task of meta learning now
if you don't know what meta learning is
let me quickly introduce the term so in
meta learning you assume you have some
sort of a distribution of tasks ahead so
let's make some examples for example
task one could be you get an image you
have a data set of images and you want
to classify them into cats or dogs and
you know you have a little data set with
labelled images and you can train test
split that and that's one task now task
two is going to be again you have a
small data set of different images but
let's just all make image examples here
but you want to locate the pedestrian so
you want to locate the human in the
image as where is the human and the task
three could be again a small database of
tasks a sorry of images and in each of
the image you want to visually
question-answer you want to or let's say
you want to point out all right there is
a ground there is a tree and there is a
question about it yeah let's take visual
question answering right we wish which
give you yes or no questions something
like this now let's just say you have
two segments you have two segments that
image so down here would be ground you
have two segments the ground okay so
these are all image tasks right these
are all perfectly fine independent tasks
each each for each one you have a small
data set now sometimes these data sets
are very very small such that you cannot
really train a state-of-the-art model on
them for example if you have medical
images oftentimes the labels of these
are very hard to get I mean there's
privacy concerns and then
you know doctors have to look at it to
produce the images costs money and so on
so it's not like you have a lot of
images and you could profit from more
images so one method that people come up
with is called transfer learning so in
transfer learning you say I have this
giant database of images let's let's
let's say this is image net right I have
this giant database image net with
labeled images what I can do is I can
use this to train a neural network let's
these are the bunch of layers of neural
network and I can train the neural
network on this big database and get
parameters theta right these are the
parameters of the neural network and
then I will basically adapt these
parameters to each task individually so
in task one sorry about that I would
then take these parameters as an input
to the neural network I would initialize
the neural network with these parameters
and then I would use this training set
in order to fine tune this is what's
called fine tuning to the task specific
parameters here Phi is so Phi 1 because
it's task 1 for task 2 I would also take
these as a starting point in order to
train its neural network to fine tune it
on this bounding box tasks in order to
obtain the parameters for task 2 right
so you can see that the progressive
retraining stage here to obtain good
initial parameters and then we adapt
these initial parameters for each task
separately in the fine-tuning stage so
this is one way we can do it another way
we can do it is called multi task
learning what we do in multi task
learning is we say well see probably an
in a neural network that can segment the
grounds is also pretty good at doing
bounding boxes like it will use some of
the same features so can't we just kind
of pull together these data sets into
one bigger data set and then
on-like if it's if and if it's an image
from task one will train on the loss of
task one and if it's an image from task
two will train on the loss of task two
and so on but we'll sort of use the same
neural network basis we just have kind
of different heads on top of them and
we'll basically so this is called multi
task learning have one shared neural
network with different outputs for the
different tasks and basically counting
on the fact that you can sort of learn
from one task what's useful in the other
now this is a good method to combine the
tasks and to basically share data
information but it will also limit you
because you now have to trade off
between the tasks like this neural
network right here this joint encoder
will never be able to will never be able
to fully gear to one task because it
also has to you know it has to perform
for the other tasks as well so you kind
of limit yourself in your top out
accuracy now maybe the regularization
effect is good so these are two methods
the first is called transfer learning
here on the left and the other is called
multitask learning now meta learning
goes a different direction meta learning
is like transfer learning but it says
well what if we don't have this giant
data set right here what what if what if
we find a way to learn these initial
parameters right so what we'll do is
we'll start out with a guess a guess of
good initial parameters let's call that
theta zero and now we have all of these
three tasks take theta zero and run
their run their fine-tuning right to
come up with with their own parameters
starting at theta zero so this is Phi
one started from theta zero and we'll
also give it to task two and task three
right and each of these tasks is going
to train on its own
training data set and then evaluate on
its own validation data set and then
report back a number so we do this for
every task and every task basically
trains this it runs through the
validation data set reports back a
generalization error and then we know
once we get all the information from all
the tests we know how good were these
initial parameters right we get a
measure of how easy is it for the tasks
to adapt these initial parameters to
their own data set and then we somehow
need to figure out a way okay these
parameters were on average 81% good can
we come up with a better set of initial
parameters theta one in some way can we
somehow find a better set of initial
parameters such that it is easier for
the tasks to adapt these initial
parameters right and even more so there
could be tasks for which we are not
seeing during this training phase right
this is kind of our so these up here
could be our trained training tasks and
this down here could be our validation
tasks
so basically we're trying to come up
with a set of initial parameters that if
a new task comes along and it takes this
thing as its initial parameters it will
be able to adapt very quickly these
initial parameters to its own data set
and most importantly it can do that it
will result in a much better model than
had the task just trained on its own
small data set from scratch so our task
is in meta-learning is basically to come
up with a learning procedure to general
to iteratively generate better and
better and better initial parameters
right and what better way to do this
that using gradient descent so this is
this is meta learning using gradient
descent is is a is the core of this
paper basically now what do you need for
gradient descent so if you want to track
go from one task to the next using SGD
or even GD gradient descent you need to
come up with a gradient now why is this
a problem in this case so this is in
this figure so this meta learning using
gradients was done in this technique
called mammal and essentially what you
can see here is that if you have you
have this set of initial parameters this
is your current best guess of these good
initial parameters and you want to come
up with a gradient of how to get an even
better set now this gradient here is
indicated by this arrow so you don't
let's imagine you don't know the
gradient yet you want to come up with a
gradient so what you'll need to do is
you'll basically have to compute the
loss function and you have to
differentiate that loss function with
respect your parameters that's down here
what the description of the orange arrow
so the your loss function of your meta
parameters is going to be the average or
the sum of the loss functions across all
of the different tasks individually so
the gradient is going to be the sum of
the gradients of these loss functions
with respect to your original parameter
now this is the difference right usually
we differentiate with respect to the
parameters that we input into the loss
function but not here what we input into
the loss function is what is at the end
of n of the task adapting to its own
parameters so this thing we input here
is a function of our initial parameters
but is not our initial parameters so
what we have is initial parameters we
give them to a task where this task runs
SGD for K steps it runs it for a number
of steps comes up with the adapted
version to its own problem that goes
into a loss function right so the this
this this thing here or the is the
neural network that finally determines
the loss function so if we want to back
propagate we can back propagate this
loss for
right through the neural network to F
the neural network is right here is
parameterized by these things we can
back propagate through that but then
we'll have to back propagate through the
optimization procedure that was used to
derive these things so that's the the
problem right here you can see this here
you start out with the initial
parameters and let's say you give them
to task 1 task 1 is going to take these
as initialization and then run SGD so
maybe it will perturb these parameters
to come up with here Phi 1 these
parameters these parameters are the
adapted version for task 1 and then at
the end of task 1 you use this character
as a neural network and you can
calculate a gradient so how would you
need to update these parameters in order
to make the loss go down and the neural
network or sorry the computation will
maybe result well you need to go up a
bit well this is too strong it will
maybe say you need to go into this
direction right here with respect to
these parameters but now the question is
how do you have to adjust your initial
parameters such that your your final
parameters will go into that direction
and that's not really clear you could
make a guess right you could make a
guess and say well if my initial
parameters just go up a bit maybe the
optimization procedure will just you
know sort of look the same but shift it
up here so something like this and then
I will end up here but that's not
guaranteed like this is a super
nonlinear procedure that you're running
it through this SGD thing and it will
basically it's an iterative recursive
procedure so it will sort of accumulate
its own nonlinear errors and that's why
what you have to do is basically you
forward propagate through SGD and then
you have to back propagate this gradient
right here
you have to back propagate this through
the entire SGD optimization procedure
and that is computationally very
expensive because if you have to come
you two lost once here for a neural
network you have to forward pass once
and the backpropagation will cost as
much as the forward propagation or maybe
twice as much a constant number but if
you run K steps of SGD you basically
have to trace back those K steps via
back propagating it through each step so
basically this is K times a back
propagation step and then
computationally that's just not feasible
for more than very few steps and so you
can only ever do very few steps you
basically accumulate your nonlinear
error because gradient descent is linear
procedure and then you get some
estimation of the gradient at the end
now if you do that for all of your tasks
then finally you can decide so maybe for
a task one here the result will be in
order to make this go up a bit you need
to shift this a bit to up and the right
right because then the gradient descent
will kind of sort of end up here and you
do this for all tasks and you average
the gradient like here then you can come
up with a final gradient for your inner
sorry for your outer model for your
initial parameters so this is a big load
of computation that Mammal does here now
there is a naive approximation and this
is exactly what we said at the beginning
right this first order mammal is the
guess that
if we want to go up a bit at the end
here why don't we shift the beginning up
a bit right and so the first order
mammal will just result in basically
looking at the gradients at the end and
sort of aggregating them right here and
then coming up with a gradient but this
is very inaccurate and generally doesn't
work well because you have to understand
how your end gradient is connected to
your initial gradient because this is
very nonlinear you can't just basically
transfer it over now implicit Mammal
this paper right here circumvents that
it circumvents the step to have to
explicitly back propagate
is gradient along the forward pass but
it's still able to come up with an
expression for how the final gradient
relates to the initial gradient so this
is quite cool and we're in this video I
would basically like to explore how this
comes about and why this comes about we
won't go through all the theory and the
proofs but I would like you to
understand that this comes about by
basically them imposing a quadratic
regularizer and therefore this quadratic
regularizer makes a very it it kind of
gives rise to a very strong connection
between this final gradient and this
initial gradient so they can basically
transform one into the other and
therefore they can compute the initial
gradient in a closed form setting or at
least in theory alright this was this
now let's go into the problem
formulation as they see it the entire
problem formulation is you want to find
these best meta-learning parameters
right and they call this the outer level
so on an outer level you want to run
gradient descent to find the best
meta-learning parameters to minimize
this function f right here now what is F
F is the average of the validation loss
function so here this is the loss
function on the test sets of the
individual tasks and the neural network
that we evaluate on the test set is the
neural network that is trained the
algorism
is that is a training algorithm is
trained on the training set of that
particular task while starting from
these parameters theta now you see there
is no prep no no dependence on the task
here there is no i down here for these
meta parameters because these are always
the same right that's the crucial point
all the tasks start from the same
initial parameters then they optimize on
their own training data set and then
they evaluate on
their own test dataset and that will
give you the loss for that particular
task and your goal is to find the meta
parameters such that this function here
the average loss that results from this
procedure is minimal okay so where they
say right here the inner level is this
algorithm component so the algorithm
starts from these from these meta
parameters and runs gradient steps on
the training data set loss now this is
just the first step right here of this
procedure of course in the next step
these are going to be replaced by the by
the Phi that by the Phi I that results
from the previous step so the first step
is run on the meta parameters and then
subsequently the task specific
parameters are updated the important
thing here is that this doesn't need to
be gradient descent actually with their
method because their method doesn't need
to back propagate through the
optimization you can think of any inner
optimization procedure that you want it
can be like a black box solver whatever
you want I'm going to be this
interesting to see how this is going to
affect something like reinforcement
learning and so on this might have
already happened and I have not looked
up this so the crucial part of the paper
I think is right here and it's sort of
you know section 2.2 but I would I would
want to point out that I think this is
the crucial part this is why the method
works ultimately why it's why it's able
to build this implicit gradient so the
section is called proximal
regularization in the inner level and
we'll go through this with a bit of
detail to have sufficient learning in
the inner level while also avoiding
overfitting alq does the inner
optimization procedure needs to
incorporate some form of regularization
so they're there they're sort their goal
here or their point here is that
if especially if these individual tasks
have small training data set you need to
have some kind of protection against
overfitting and that and that and they
say since mammal uses a small number of
gradient steps this corresponds to early
stopping and can be interpreted as a
form of regularization and Bayes in
prior so mammal is this this previous
method this basic method that back
propagates through the optimization
procedure and since it does this since
it back propagates through the
optimization procedure it's
computationally really limited to only
run very few forward optimization steps
because it then has to back propagate
through each one right needs to store
each one so it's computationally limited
so by necessity it uses only a small
number of gradient steps and therefore
this is kind of early stopping and we
know to prevent overfitting one thing
you can do is to stop before your
training accuracy reaches full zero and
you can stop earlier than that ideally
at a point when your validation accuracy
reaches the low point but they say
basically this this limited number of
steps is a form of regularization now of
course in in this new method we we don't
have this constraint anymore we can run
our inner optimization to super
convergence and therefore we we don't
have this implicit regularizer anymore
and we'll have to make up for that they
say in cases like ill-conditioned
optimization landscapes and medium short
learning we may want to take many
gradient steps which poses two
challenges for mammal first we need to
store and differentiate through the long
optimization path of alch
which imposes a considerable computation
and memory burden right that's what we
said second the dependence of the model
parameters phi i on the meta parameters
shrinks and vanish
as the number of gradient steps in Al
gross making meta-learning
difficult so what they're saying is if
you optimize your inner optimization
algorithm to the very end then it is not
very it's it's dependence and especially
for gradient descent it's linear
dependence on the initial parameters so
on the meta parameters shrinks the more
optimization steps you do because the
more and more you're going to basically
forget about your initialization move
away from that and move to a local
optimum from which you could reach you
know from many many different
initializations so that's still a
question of whether that's happening but
this does the idea here right if you're
at the local optimum you could have
reached that from any sort of point and
there's going to be very little
information about the end of the
procedure from the beginning and
therefore if you want to calculate the
gradient that's going to be like super
inaccurate and they say to overcome
these limitations so they they solve
these two things in one right here we
consider a more explicitly regularized
algorithm so what they'll say is they'll
say we don't just want to optimize this
inner objective so this would be here so
the we don't just want to find the
minimum of this inner loss function
that's a one goal we have but the other
goal we have is to stay close to the
initial parameters and that's where this
regularizer in comes in here
so this basically says we we want with
our parameters here that we are
optimizing we want to find them such
that they minimize this loss function
right you know really minimize it find
the best point but also with a trade-off
of lambda we want to stay close to the
to the initial parameters that we
started from right this is this is the
initial parameters and the closeness is
measured in the l2 norm so it's a
quadratic regularizer
on how close your you might know for
you know initial supervised learning or
something that sometimes you do
something like plus lambda times the l2
norm of the weight so this will be
called weight regularization weight
decay l2 normalization something like
this where you regularize your weights
such that you stay close to the zero
point right implicitly in this there is
a minus zero given but here you want to
stay close to your initial parameters so
the inner optimization is no longer just
minimizing the loss on the training
dataset the inner optimization is that
and with Alec star we denote if so if
Alec has a star we say that the this is
this is referring not to the procedure
of the algorithm but to the minimum that
the algorithm has found right so Alec
star means the algorithm has optimized
this inner procedure to its minimum
which is a balance of the training loss
of that task and staying close to the
original parameters and this I think
this they say that here the proximal
regularization term in equation 3
encourages Theta Phi I to remain close
to theta thereby retaining a strong
dependence throughout this is why their
method works and we're going to see in
the math right soon how exactly this
this how exactly they are able through
this to establish this implicit gradient
correspondence so they formulate their
entire algorithm as follows we want to
find the best meta learning parameters
by minimizing the function f where f is
the average losses and L here now that's
the test set loss
the average validation loss for each
task
of the parameters that the inner
optimization procedure finds when it
runs to its optimum now this you can see
here this is already different from the
original mammal the original mammal was
simply running it for a number of steps
and now we're really running it to the
optimum at least in the ideal case what
does the inner optimization algorithm do
the alux star here minimizes this
function G retina G has two arguments G
has G has these parameters which are the
local parameters and these are the meta
parameters and we only optimize the
local parameters but we take these as
initial and then fine-tune them where
the function G is defined as the
training loss of the local parameters
plus this closeness regularizer okay
cool
now the question of course is how does
that lead to gradient descent so
ultimately we want to minimize this
function f right here so we have we're
going to have to do something like DF by
D theta right - in order to run gradient
descent we need to calculate this
gradient because we need to do gradient
descent so what's that going to be
that's going to be of course since F is
a is this one over m up here right the
the gradient simply distributes over
that sum now it's the gradient or this
already derivative of each of these
inner loss functions let's go with this
L star I theta that's basically what you
have right here okay so in order to take
the gradient of F we need to be able to
take the T we need to be able to derive
these loss functions and you can see
right here theta is not the argument to
the loss function theta is the argument
to this inner procedure so by the chain
right now this gives us this the chain
rule says we derive the outer thing with
respect to its input that's this part
right here the gradient of the loss with
respect to the neural network and that
thing here that's the Alec Star so we
need the gradient of the loss function
with respect to the end parameters of
the optimization procedure now that's
easy that's we know how to do that that
is the or register so if you remember
the drawing at the beginning this
gradient is the end arrow right here
this is easy this is one backward
propagation this is regular supervised
learning back prop right you have
parameters of a neural network a
gradient for the loss function cool the
hard part is to have the derivative of
the algorithm itself with respect to the
current through the meta parameters so
this is going to be this here is going
to be a vector it's the gradient with
respect to these parameters and this is
going to be a matrix and the matrix will
relate basically one dimension each
dimension of this vector
sorry that's it's going to be a product
between this thing and this thing and it
will result in this thing so the left
thing is the gradient we want this is
the derivative of the entire thing
that's this now the right thing is the
gradient at the end of the optimization
procedure and this matrix here relates
the individual dimension of this end
gradient to the gradient that we want
right this is a matrix that relates the
two in a linear fashion this is what
we're looking how how do we need to
change the initial parameters in order
to change the end parameters by a
certain a certain way
because we only need we only know this
but we want to know this so how do we
calculate this thing here this Jacobian
that's a question right how do we derive
the the algorithmic procedure this thing
rear here and the paper goes on to say
well okay yeah so we need to do this
this is the entire gradient descent
optimization procedure so we must
compute this thing right here and they
just throw it in your face it's this
boom shocka the bomb
this thing here done let's go on know so
you can you can see it's it's basically
putting this just right here but we kind
of want to explore where that comes from
so the fact you can see here you can
derive this gradient as a closed form
expression of the inverse of a matrix
that contains this is the identity
matrix contains somehow this lambda
factor that we saw before and it
contains this Hessian matrix of the
training loss right so this is this end
gradient that we can calculate easily
and the second derivative of that is the
Hessian which is basically the curvature
in the landscape of that loss but
nowhere in this thing is the is the SGD
procedure showing up even though this
thing here is the SGD procedure and
that's pretty impressive and we're going
to look at how that comes about so so
where where do we start first let's take
this let's take this G right here this G
function right and let's calculate the
derivative with respect to the in these
parameters right here so let's go for
this end gradient what's this end
gradient going to be so we'll derive the
G
with respect to the these parameters
alright so this is the sum this first
thing is pretty easy it's going to be
the gradient of this loss function loss
function is a scalar right so we can
this we can calculate something one
backward prop through the network the
second thing we can also do pretty
easily this is an l2 norm alright we
know how to derive a square so the two
comes down and the the this will simply
result in the this vector right here so
it's going to be lambda times Phi minus
theta okay now this was relatively easy
now imagine what happens when in this
particular thing we have one additional
information namely that F the inside of
F F we will always optimize to the end
we will always optimize this to its
minimum right this star denotes that the
inner optimization procedure will always
go to the minimum of that function so
what do we know about the minimum of the
function we know that it's gradient at
that particular point is zero all right
this is the this is an important part so
now we can restructure so if we take one
to the right I might actually use black
here because it's kind of burning my
eyes
we can isolate this part right here so
we say the Phi is equal to first of all
let's um let's take this to the right
side so we'll have this gradient right
here and I'm just gonna write L of Phi
let's keep the Hat alive we'd have to
divide this by lambda right and then
bring over the
theta so we have a close we have an
expression that says at the optimum the
parameters Phi the inner parameters are
going to be given by this expression now
that's pretty pretty cool but we know
also that these parameters aren't just
you know parameters per se they depend
on these parameters right the end
parameters depend on the initial
parameters because then we use the
initial parameters to initialize these
end parameters so these are actually a
function of the initial parameters so
what we can do is we can derive this
using read again let's use blue we can
derive this thing by the initial
parameters right how do the end
parameters relate to the initial
parameters this is our basic question
all along but we now have an exact
expression for the end parameters which
we didn't have before before we just
knew they came about by SGD so important
to say this only works at the optimum
right this is at the optimum that this
relation counts not anywhere and the
paper is abusing this quite a bit right
here so what is this - if we derive this
thing here with respect to theta it's
simply giving us the identity matrix
right this is now our our Jacobian that
appears here
it's simply giving us this then this 1
divided by lambda is going to stay and
now it gets a bit tricky because these
things right here of course are also a
function of theta so essentially this
means we this thing right here is a
gradient of a function of another
function of theta so we can apply the
chain rule again since this is already
the first derivative it will give us the
second derivative with respect to the
loss
function right here of with whatever
goes into the loss function so that
times the inner derivative now the inner
derivative is simply how to derive again
D Phi by the theta okay now I'm just
okay yes so you can see first of all
interesting that the expression here are
the expression that we're looking to
find appears in the expression itself
right since since these parameters
appear over here as a function argument
as well we'll get basically this
expression here twice but we can
reformulate that and find that the the
this term this Jacobian is basically
this here inverted so the matrix we're
looking for is sorry the inverse
Jacobian the matrix we're looking for is
given by this quantity right here the
identity matrix minus this Hessian term
right here okay and this is exactly what
you see appearing here this is exactly
that so the derivative we're looking for
sorry this is actually the Jacobian not
the inverse that's my bad what you're
looking for is given by this expression
now my eraser got stuck hello
so that's how that appears you see it's
the same thing if I had done everything
correctly and so this this you do by
simply shipping this to the other side
which will make it the the inverse right
so you divide you basically divide both
sides by this and then you get this as
an inverse now why does this work again
I want to stress why did we get this
identity here why were we able to
express get a closed-form solution to
the for the inner thing or sorry for the
end parameters in terms of the beginning
parameters that doesn't have STD first
reason because we optimized to the end
to the optimum that's why we got the
equals zero right here second reason
because we have this regularizer you see
this directly comes from heat from this
expression right here if we wouldn't
have this regularizer then we could not
make this expression we could not get
phi as a stand-alone quantity here and
therefore this derivation wouldn't work
now why is this important because if you
look back into your drawing what you're
basically doing is you are imposing a
quadratic regularizer around this
initial point right here and that
creates this very strong connection
between the end gradient and the initial
gradient so now when you're optimizing
when you have a training loss of the
inner tasks and maybe the training loss
looks something like it looks something
like like this right here so SGD will it
would go right to the very inner point
right here if you just let SGD run it
would go there but now since you have
this regularizer SGD needs to find a
trade-off point between the two so what
it will do is it will probably go some
we're stopped somewhere here so it will
now have two forces pulling on it the
first force will be this quantity right
here and the second force will be
pulling it back towards this and you can
pretty much count so now SGD cannot just
go to any point right here it cannot not
go to any isoline these are not equal
anymore
mainly it will go to the one point that
points into the direction of this
quadratic right here so since it's a
quadratic we have closed-form formulas
for relating one gradient on the
quadratic namely the one out here with
the gradient there back here so we can
express this Jacobian in closed form
because this is a quadratic because we
have this regularizer because you have
these basically two forces pulling on
this point in opposite direction one
pointing towards the training loss and
one pointing towards the inside of the
quadratic so that's why this method
works okay I can recommend Ferran who's
ours blog post he has some very nice
animations of why this basically
restricts where gradient descent can go
I can I can link to it in the
description it's pretty cool to see I
don't have it open right now so what
does that give us the implicit model
agnostic meta learning I mammal this is
what this paper suggests while not
converged to do sample a backbench of a
bunch of tasks right for each task
compute the meta gradient G average
these gradients to get a gradient for
the outer parameters and then do
gradient descent on the outer parameters
pretty easy how do you do this how do
you do this in place implicit meta
gradient this is this procedure right
here so what you are going to do is
met the parameters theta you initialize
your parameters with the theta by the
way they don't need to be
initializations that can be actually any
sort of hyper parameters that this
algorithm takes any parameterization of
this algorithm will do fine I just
always said initial parameters such that
it it gets easier but it can be any sort
of hyper parameters of the inner tasks
obtain task parameters using iterative
optimization solver such that the the
inner parameters are close to the
optimum of that algorithm so they
actually extend this also in theory not
so that you do not don't have to
optimize the inner objective really to
the optimum but you can be like Delta
close to it that's pretty useful and
that's in the part of the paper that we
won't go over because this video would
be like super long but I invite you to
read it if you're interested then you
compute the partial outer level gradient
so this this would be your partial
gradient your V would be this gradient
at the end right the gradient at the end
of the optimization procedure with
respect to your validation datasets
this is one back problem now we need to
relate that end gradient to the
beginning and that's and we do that by
multiplying it with this matrix inverted
right here now because obtaining the
entire matrix this is the Hessian matrix
and invert it is very memory and
computation intensive because if you
have D parameters in your neural network
this is going to be a D by D matrix so
if you have five million parameters this
is going to be 25 million million size
matrix is just not possible and that's
why this paper extends this method to a
second degree of approximation namely
you don't have to compute the exact
inverse you just have to compute
something that is very
close to the inverse times this integral
this final gradient and a good method to
do this is this conjugate gradient
method and that method is able to to
basically use the fact that you can
compute Hessian vector products without
having to compute the Hessian as a
matrix this you can also do with a sort
of modified back propagation algorithm
also won't go in here but you use
iterative solver for example conjugate
gradient along with reverse mode
differentiation to compute Hessian
vector products to compute GI so GI is
going to be the final gradient pulled
back through this matrix right here to
give you the beginning gradient this
meta gradient ok so two approximations
here first approximation you don't
actually have to solve to the variant
you can solve it Delta close and second
approximation you don't actually have to
compute the inverse of that final Brady
sorry
compute the multiplication of the final
gradient with the inverse of this matrix
right here you can also find something
that's a delta prime close to that and
they have a bunch of theory of that this
still works they compare this of course
to the other algorithms they observe
that their algorithm uses substan
substantially less memory and well
substantially less memory and
substantially less compute time once you
go up to a number of inner gradient
steps and it works better than this
first order mammal so this first order
mammal was our kind of initial guess of
how we could do this this tends to
perform very poorly as you can see there
there oh you cannot you can't actually
see that here that their method is
better but their method is better and
uses less time
because you have this container
conjugate gradient optimizer so if this
is the this is the outer optimizer okay
so this is the error plot of how well
are these methods are able to
approximate the true gradient so if you
could compute this true outer gradient
you know that we did with mammal but we
optimized to the end how close are you
getting of course the problem with this
method right here is that you do these
approximations to you do these
approximations and those could hurt you
but the problem with mammal is that your
back propagating through the
optimization procedure and that means
the nonlinear errors could sort of
accumulate and as you can see here even
though both might eventually you know
get to the to the zero error if you give
them enough inner gradient steps
especially at the low inner gradient
step regime the implicit mammal is much
better than mammal now I've just said
the errors accumulate but the effect
probably here is that the fact that with
mammal you don't actually do good inner
enough inner steps to reach a good
enough optimum of the inner tasks so
these inner gradient of the tasks their
gradients when they're still very not
optimized and therefore they are a very
bad estimate for your outer gradient
then when you do more gradient steps so
that actually hurts you more which is
also a bit surprising to me and then at
the end you see these conjugate gradient
steps this is when you approximate this
matrix inverse if you just do two steps
then at some point that error dominates
but if you do more steps you can reach a
much lower error and ten steps isn't
that much for an algorithm like this as
you can see here the ten steps
your computation time will still in in
the regime of many gradient steps will
still be lower than the original mammal
and then they actually test this thing
and of course they're the best at pretty
much everything I don't want to go into
the exact details here I invite you to
check out the paper for that to check
out if you're interested in the proofs
and the approximation guarantees and
with that bye bye